la galerie du théâtre de champ fleuri
accueille depuis le 1er avril et ce
jusqu'au 28 mai une exposition d'art
contemporain
l'idée est simple prendre des artistes
en devenir qui ont déjà exposé à la
ligne galerie d'art contemporain unique
à la réunion
il est confronté dans cet espace du
théâtre alors tout d'abord il a fallu
prendre en considération le lieu dans
lequel on intervenait donc c'est un
théâtre donc j'ai choisi de partir déjà
sur des oeuvres très visible très
spectaculaire très belle très accessible
et de cette première idée la benjamine
voilà j'ai un peu choisi des oeuvres uns
des artistes qui gravite un peu autour
de la ligne depuis un petit moment
voilà donc on s'arrêtait à neuf artistes
le corps en spectacle une exposition
collective regroupant une partie des
artistes émergents ou confirmés qui
gravitent autour du lieu le thème c'est
le grand spectacle donc voila mon heure
un théâtre donc on est un à fond dedans
donc l'idée c'est donc vraiment montrer
des pièces des oeuvres qui sont
accessibles faciles belle contemporaine
voilà des illustrations un grand rideau
théâtre des grands masques des choses
pas très belle très accessible
mais en même temps qu'on différents
niveaux de lecture parce que toutes ces
oeuvres présentées elles sont issues ou
de performances déjà effectués ou
deux démarches très très engagé en fait
et donc voilà l'idée c'est de montrer
les oeuvres très belle et à côté de ça
qui l ont un fond vraiment un très très
important et une démarche plutôt très
importante
parmi les artistes qui exposent tatiana
pachamama trouve un véritable intérêt à
cette exposition collective
l'occasion pour elle de voir plusieurs
univers dialoguer ensemble
l'oeuvre de tatiana choisi par claire
viardet pour cette exposition s'intitule
nébulosité il s'agit d'un nuage en fait
en textile c'est une pièce très très
légère en fait qui est fait en tissu qui
a été cuit et c'est une pièce hyper
légère en fait hyper cdu séductrice et
comme son expo s'appelle le grand
spectacle et elle joue en fait avec
cette ce côté séduction de l'art
contemporain qui a un côté voilà où elle
où elle recherche en fait ces pièces qui
séduisent donc est là elle m'a proposé
de présenter cette pièce qui est
justement là dans une forme de séduction
répulsion et qu'ils pouvaient répondre
justement
à son projet d'exposition l'art qui se
démocratise l'art qui s'offrent à tous
les regards l'exposition dans un lieu
public comme les théâtres départementaux
passé commun nous les gens ne viennent
pas avoir une exposition tellement le
spectacle et se retrouve contraint
finalement à revoir cette expo donc à
découvrir deux parties neuf pièces je
pense qu'il ya plein de choses telles
actions qui sont mises en place pour un
peu de démocratiser l'art contemporain
pour l'offrir au public et sert cette
exposition par vraiment ces principes là
aussi c'est que comme j'ai des départs
ces désastres elle accessible donc je
pense qu'un enfant peut avoir un regard
un adulte à plusieurs personnes peut
avoir des parents regardent qu'on soit
connaisseur ou par le grand spectacle à
découvrir au théâtre de champ fleuri
jusqu'au 28 mai